[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'attends ta son journal pour l'airé
louvel j'espère qu'elles seront chauds
sociaux tels voyages grand portail et
barnes images sont foutus des ptic
romera le petit écho de la forêt c'est
très serré il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le tue des cours de
l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons que dit notre journal au
écouter certes les fans tel est pris qui
croyait prendre
hier il a fait très chaud et bien si je
me ferais le bon une petite sieste ou
tard elles ont vraiment dormir au moins
de temps qu'il ne faut pour dire des
bêtes ou battus tous cas je l'espère une
bonne petite sieste un pavé ya rien
d'autre à faire pour une telle chaleur y
tous au dormir du sommeil du juste mais
même moselle de la cigogne elle ne
faisait pas la sienne dans ce cas
comment mais vous dormez si je ne
m'abuse
mais c'est abominable mais vous n'avez
pas honte
parce qu'arles abonnés politique ouah
excusez moi vous aurez le réveiller non
mais j'ai fait un cauchemar lequel j'ai
rêvé qu'on me volait mêlée tu sais ce
qui va vous arriver si vous dormez tout
le temps alors debout sacré vous y la
cigogne bliss la malheureuse tosca à la
suivre dans la clairière regarder les
taux ce cas on dirait deux bébés mais on
ne dort pas en plein jour pourquoi parce
que ça ne se fait pas voilà pourquoi je
vais vite des billets ces deux paresseux
comment vous allez voir j -p
louis au travail voilà où nous vient
d'en faire un combat et pouvant table
moi aussi j'aurais dit non que je devais
travailler moi aussi allongé toujours
debout devant ça fait bon qu'on se marre
qui continue le mien aussi
rassurez-vous vous n'allez pas
travailler bon alors on peut se
rendormir
nous nous nous allons jouer jouer croix
est là pour quoi pour vous empêcher de
dormir en plein après midi nous allons
jouer à cache-cache comme quand nous
étions bon bain nous allons y faisant
contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
louise ip tosca dur d'accepter de jouer
à cache-cache 7 8 9 et 10 attention
jamais caché ou non je saurai vous
trouvez je vais vous découvrir où sont
ils
mais où sont ils notre bonne cigognes
avait beau chercher elle ne trouvait pas
ses camarades de jeu je ne les trouve
pas c'est vraiment ridicule tous cas jp
louis avait trouvé une astuce pour
échapper aux jeux obligatoire que leur
avait imposé cette cigogne et que
l'école les ego la seconde est les
forêts et fort recours légaux du sycot
diatribe
que vois-je pour chanter au lieu de
jouer et on est mieux mourir que de hors
jeu casque auch très dumoutier krimo des
incroyables
quand je pense que j'ai fini km pour
vous trouver également des dents et vit
à londres amusé ou que nous sommes
refusés
je n'en suis plus bas et forêts à vire
mademoiselle je suis épuisée ma voiture
je crois que je vais faire une petite
sieste une sieste voir et pas le droit
et et y est crédit baudier je m'en bat
michel fugain
allez on dit de battre nous voulions
jouer écoles quelle horreur
ouais bon j'ai fait un cauchemar
abominable
j'ai cru que vous vouliez jouer à cache
cache
mais oui mais oui mademoiselle de la
cigogne a été prise à son propre piège
il ne faut jamais imposé aux autres
qu'on voudrait pas faire soi même n'est
ce pas faire téléphone à bientôt pour
une prochaine édition du petit etc ou de
la forêt
voyons voyons que dit notre journal aux
op coûter cher téléphone
tel est pris qui croyait prendre
ir il a fait très chaud et bien si je
m'offrais lebon une petite sieste
batarelle en france et environ autant
qu'il le faut pour dire des dépouilles
battu le score
je vais faire une bonne petite sieste
pour v il n'y a rien d'autre à faire
pour une telle chaleur y tous au dormir
du sommeil du juste mais même moselle de
la cigogne elle ne faisait pas la sienne
dans ce cas comment mais vous dormez si
je ne m'abuse c'est abominable mais vous
n'avez pas honte
parce qu'alors la bonne immunité quoi
excusez moi vous aurez le réveiller non
mais j'ai fait un cauchemar lequel j'ai
rêvé qu'on me volait mêlée tu sais ce
qui va vous arriver si vous dormez tout
le temps alors debout sacré vous y la
cigogne oubli sur la malheureuse tosca à
la suivre dans la clairière regarder les
taux ce cas vous dirait de bp mais on ne
dort pas en plein jour pourquoi parce
que ça ne se fait pas voilà pourquoi je
vais vite des billets ces deux
paraissons comment vous allez voir si
louis au travail ou là où l'on vient
d'en faire un combat et pouvant table
gossip heavy ils ont que je devais
travailler moi aussi allongé de jours de
boudin
enfin c'est bon qu'on se marre qui
continue le mieux aussi
rassurez-vous vous n'allez pas
travailler bon alors on peut se
rendormir
nous nous nous allons jouer jouer quoi
elle avoir quoi pour vous empêcher de
dormir au plein après midi nous allons
jouer à cache-cache comme quand nous
étions bobin nous allons rire
faisant contre mauvaise fortune bon
coeur
luigi pitot ce cas dur à accepter de
jouer à cache-cache 7 8 9 et 10
attention givet cacher ou non je saurai
vous trouvez je vais vous découvrir où
sont ils mais où sont ils
notre bonne cigognes avait beau chercher
elle ne trouvait pas ses camarades de
jeu je ne les trouve pas c'est vraiment
ridicule tous cas jp louis avait trouvé
une astuce pour échapper au joug
obligatoire que leur avait imposé cette
cigogne et que l'école les ego la
seconde est les forêts éco recours
légaux des cigognes atrabile
que vois je pour chanter au lieu de
jouer et on est mieux je n'arrive qu'en
dehors je cache cache très du mot dieu
krimo des incroyables
quand je pense que j'ai fait des
kilomètres pour vous trouver lesquels on
est bien ici alors amusé ou que nous
sommes refusés
je n'en suis plus bas ils vont réagir
badma vert je suis épuisé à votre âge je
crois que je vais faire une petite
sieste une sieste vous n'avez pas le
droit et et y est crédit baudier je m'en
bats c'est bon allez on dit de m nous
voulions jouer parce que quelle horreur
ouais bon j'ai fait un cauchemar
abominons j'ai cru que vous vouliez
jouer à casque mais oui mais oui
mademoiselle de la cigogne a été prise à
son propre piège
ils ne font jamais imposé aux autres
qu'on voudrait pas faire soi même n'est
ce pas faire téléphone à bientôt pour
une prochaine édition du petit écho de
la forêt voyais rien shirt et les fans
quelles sont les nouvelles
turkia boris le loup a changé qu'a donc
pu encore inventé ce brave boris au
mardi phie la fourmi fait son ménage
dans ce cas digère sa lettre quotidienne
mademoiselle dollars si l'on fait la
sieste et moi moi moi je sais pas quoi
faire c'est la voix de boris
il apprend à compter au nom ne peut pas
faire comme si l'on fabriqué n'aurait
allez voir ça de plus près des digues
qui vaut trois sous gip lelièvre arrive
à labège ou de porte plus du troc autres
du tout mabri staff d'être conduits à
bangui et tu apprends à compter donc
offert junos tubes pour vert bah moi
vouloir rester fois mais tu ferais bien
de venir faire un pas de course avec moi
mais eux non avec tous travaillent chez
moi à voir la maison pas les tensions
l'avocat ron nettoyer pavé si répartira
stick cuivre tapis ce coin est pas voir
tempère la vie c'est les traits qui
t'arrive être lucchi assas de
responsability il était et vidéo que
boris avait changé subitement et sip
lelièvre n'en revenais pas c'est grave
je vous le dis bien si beauvais va
changer complètement
comment et tulle et d'argovie la fourmi
et travaille comme ville a fourbi ils
raisonnent comme vive et la fourmi
incroyable mais vrai mais je ne crois
pas je viens les voir boris après imax
se précipita chez boris prisse si tu
venais jouer à lou perché avec moi au
voile pourquoi wade voit travailler
travailler travailler
incroyable mais vrai la nouvelle figure
de la forêt est arrivée aux oreilles de
fifi la fourmi si comme je te le dis
incroyable
boris travail le respect sont ménagerie
bourré c'est pire que moi croyais à mes
frais fifi décida d'en avoir le coeur
net il se rendit chez boris et tu as
bien nettoyer sous les tapis
tu n'es pas fait tony g pourquoi tu
décidé de travailler comme moi parce que
moi vouloir être quelqu'un d'autre et
moi y arriver voilà si boris avait
tellement changé la forêt ne serait plus
la forêt il fallait faire quelque chose
c'est une idée qui je sais comment faire
redevenir boris tel qu'il était avant
croyant
mais vrai ou que je suis rusé et louis
le rusé couru chez paris selon moi pas
voir ta bave arte voix voire d'un col à
ses coûts et a pu nettoyer grenier à la
cave
dommage pour le quad hommages continuent
à travailler mais c'est tant pis pour
toi pourquoi tu tousses que je t'avais
préparer chez moi un merveilleux non
mais lui eu qu un gâteau régate ou à
quoi que tôt au miel avec des noix et
des raisins secs icloud
alors moi ne plus vouloir ressembler à
fifi boire avant lui gourmande doit
vouloir redevenir moi courir c'est toi
bien que series et je sais trouver le
moyen de faire redevenir eux-mêmes les
loups qui veulent changer le gâteau de
louis était excellent parce qu'on m'a
dit parce qu'on ne m'a pas invité à
goûter incroyable mais vrai à bientôt
cher téléphone pour une prochaine
édition du petit écho de la forêt
o o que lisez jeu cher téléphone un
arbre mort est tombé barre le chemin des
noisetiers très ennuyeux tosca passe
souvent par le chemin des noisetiers
alors tu vois ton ce cas c'est facile
devant des barres de fer
regardez et je dirais bien des primes
c'est facile et très remuant fait comme
on voit un possible le croire
je suis trop lourde et je suis trop
vieux regardez en fait tu vas voir les
une deux et trois villes crac et alors
tu pourras plus jamais allé sur ces de
la laitue son gaz tout l'est jamais faut
faire comme co faut attendre à ce bien
c'est dit il le brave zip à la demander
de l'aide aux frères k stores qui
arrivèrent bien vite sur les lieux
nous allons construire une grande grue
et nous attachant l'arbre à une chaîne
et la grue n'aura plus qu'à le monte et
le placer hors du semaine au chevet des
battants on veut du patron je dis bravo
mettez vous au travail est pas tout de
suite pourquoi il faut que nous
construisions la grue d'avant nous
devant auparavant faire les pleins
commander le matériel dont sur la grue
voir si elle mêle avait monté pour
l'amener ici la remontée voir si elle
même est un ça va prendre un mois au
moins l'un d'eux et non trois à la vôtre
est avant tout un moyen musique couru
chez lui le runner qui arriva avec max
le corbeau alors louis cambon vd c'est
un arbre ça nous avions déjà ils barrent
la route reliant fin était en vie quand
on ne peut pas le déplacer c'est évident
alors c'est tout simple il s'agit tout
bonnement de creuser un tunnel par
dessous ou que je suis rusé
à fin février à l'aller via un bébé vous
êtes fous moi je vais les louer à crever
nous avons l'habitude mais moi j'ai peur
des tunnels et je n'y mettrai jamais les
pattes
ni ma carapace d'ailleurs et l'idée wa10
vie si le la dation casta un ballon
rouge
elle va c'est le mal de l'air adri moi
je reviens j'ai l'idée des vip
il gît couru chez fifi la fourmi ils
relèvent bien de temps en temps roger
dubois non oui alors tu ne devrais pas
mon chien aboie tout entier non je suis
au régime
alors j -pf il a demandé une idée à
boris le loup mettez les faits tout
simple est mort a basé sa la loi 101 et
de la forêt mois allaient demander
conseil aux frères castro s'est déjà
fait à l'ol où il ira faire alors moque
c'est déjà fait et tout le monde se
retrouve un devant l'arbre qui paraît le
sentier mois aux voiries des normes et
mon sac elles doivent émettre bombe soir
boum-boum plus d'arbres est morte et
nous nous avons tous marre aussi
il fallait pour tous trouvé un moyen car
je pense que nous sommes tous là avec
nous ne trouvons pas d'idées ça y est on
est une idée encore rue des monts un
train et les formidables mon idée c'est
dit
nous allons tous bons même le nom de
l'arbre mort et avons commandement nous
le pouvons tous ensemble pour l'instant
rien n'est aussi où nous sauve rusé et
ce qui fut dit fut fait l'arbre ou là et
le chemin des noisetiers fut libéré je
vais pouvoir aller me régaler de laitue
120 ce seront mes amis si j'avais dû
m'en passer je n'aurais fait une maladie
on a bien raison de dire que l'union
fait la force
n'est ce pas cher téléphone mais oui
mais oui soit l'on ne peut rien 1
plusieurs
on peut tout mais oui à bientôt sur
petit et les femmes pour une prochaine
édition du petit écho de la forêt voyons
voyons voyons que dit notre journal mais
si mais si haut et coûter cher téléphone
il faut de tout pour faire un monde et
c'est bien vrai il faut des téléphones
des hiboux et bien d'autres choses
encore mais oui mais oui il fait qu'il
m'a répondu je ne sais pas il n'a
répondu celle faux missile
je n'ai rien contre les renards mais
c'est quand même une drôle d'aura c'est
vrai en plus ils sont rivés nicole
démentait cependant de son côté louis le
retard il devine ce qu'elle m'a répondu
mais je sais pas ça leur honneur non
si aller cueillir les fruits mais c'est
quand même une drôle de razz c'est vrai
elles sont bavardes avare les dix ans
égoïste de son côté tosca la tortue
avait couru mais oui couru et
mademoiselle de la cigogne
si maintenant les renards se permet
d'insulter les fourmis remarquez ce
n'est rien contre les renards mais c'est
quand même une drôle d'arras
mademoiselle de la cigogne était allé
informer les deux frères question de ce
qui était arrivé à renard n'a pas le
droit de répondre ainsi aux animaux
honnête mais louis est aussi un âne et
maloney ça reste à prouver
pourquoi parce qu'il est un renard et
alors alors c'est tout et c'est assez
inquiet de la tournure des événements
les deux frères k stores allait revoir
oui le renard même un bon lot et
m'écoutent arrête de pleurer comme ça
il ya tout à fourrure est à l'honneur il
aime lee deux frères décidèrent de
réagir très vite ils se rendirent toutes
affaires cessantes chez mademoiselle de
la cigogne
pourquoi me regarde et vous ainsi jo
parce que vous avez des plumes blanches
et alors c'est ravissant ben may se
trouve ça un peu bizarre
sinon on n'a pas parlé ainsi aux animaux
on est dans adp ou large croise bleus
nous n'avons rien contre les cigognes
mais c'est dans deux races scandalisé de
ce qu'elle avait autour du mademoiselle
de la cigogne se précipite dans le
potager de tosca oui tous cas ils ont
dit que les cigognes était une drôle de
race je ne suis pas raciste mais les
cigognes sont une droite
je vous en prie vous n'êtes qu'une
tortue après tout et les tortues sont in
de retard à ce jeu c'est tant pis pour
vous et quand on n'est qu'une tortue on
a la pudeur de se taire
tosca complètement démoralisé alla se
faire consoler par boris le loup mais
moi pas du tout le sustt la plèvre mois
aimait beaucoup le loup pourtant un
petit colis ou ce groupe où l'on croit
nos bonnes audiences cordes et de la
race dit long on se casse une immense
tristesse s'était abattue sur notre
forêt que j'ai honte d'être une famille
et moi higuain york loué nous des
castors et cesser de pleurer mais habite
arras importe peu l'important c'est ce
que nous sommes au fond de nous mêmes
regardez moi je suis encore beau et que
j'en fais une maladie croyez moi il faut
de tout pour faire un monde est ce cher
mox bien raisonné sport sur téléphone
il faut de tout pour faire un monde à
bientôt pour une prochaine édition il
petit écho de la forêt excusé pour
chercher l'islam est trop drôle
attendez je vais vous lire l'article max
le corbeau a voulu dire de ne pas oser
procès sans émoi quoi vous ressemblez
encore bondir une balance mardi
mais vous êtes ridicule oui si vous
n'êtes riddick et moi impossible y avait
les pattes de longueur riri
mais pas de son longue c'est vrai mais
si je n'ai pas besoin de monter sur une
balançoire pour paraître grandes étapes
mme lauzen de la cigogne avait visé
juste et pas ton c'est long quand cette
maudite y gagne
mais tu peur de voir si tu veux
carassins il faut en faire fabriquer une
paire ou qu'elle sut risée et sur les
conseils de louis leur honneur max la
demande et aux frères castors devait
confectionner des échasses de quelle
longueur les veux tu t es chasse prions
que les pâtes tomates brésil de l'acide
rien et pourquoi un 6ème sur riddick est
à côté de moi
aussitôt les deux frères questeur se
mirent tout travail et le lot 2 me max
tout fier partis se promener dans
l'euphorie tient debout
je suis pas bon je suis fille si la
fourmi excuse moi c'est fait mais vu de
toute ma hauteur tu peux pas révéler ce
qu'elle pluie boxe le géo croise tout ce
que tu obtiens un caillou
ce n'est pas un caillou c'est ma carte
pass ou bêta dans tosca depuis que je
suis devenu géant
tout le monde me paraît un ridicule map
était alors à 7,3 des lunettes triomphe
aux deux plus belles mecs continué sa
promenade et oh le joli c'est ça c'est
ça je suis un lapin et toi tu es un
corbeau monté en graine
mais c'est toi louise intérêts par koné
je suis si grand bal plein hésitation
danois grains de raisin ça n'est pas du
réseau mais s'il n'y a pas un endroit
bien tu te trompes ça n'est que du
gravier amont un peu déconfite route
même max et doit bien et découvrit
paurisse de loups qui dégustent être un
pot de miel etc et images
mary bybowl mieux quand tu y es tu toi
mais mieux c'est mon dessert préféré
alors moi partager avec toi le pouvant
se pencher le pauvre géo dû renoncer à
se régaler il décide d'aller rendre
visite à mademoiselle de la cigogne
bonjour pâte et iraniens sur la
mangouste roubaix nord cigogne est je
suis max max le crapaud géant
mon pauvre grand que je vous plais pas
moi parce que j'ai ans comme vous êtes
vous allé prendre froid la oumma du
temps mais si mais si vous allez
attraper un rhume qui se transformer en
bronchite qui se transformer en play
money alors alors radio max mais je ne
veux pas mourir c'est le prix aidez-moi
honte et c'est affreux monde bois n'ont
voulu être un jeu et puis je meurs de
faim
vous n'aurez qu'à venger impossible avec
ces maudits des échasses
attendez moi vous la mettez vous rien vu
vous vous êtes fait mal mon pauvre petit
big boss seulement à la tête mais j'ai
compris il va devenir comme un manteau
pitié des patrons courte mais oui match
a très vite compris qu'il ne faut pas
s'être flatte ou des autres c'est ainsi
qu'on fait mal à la tête
n'est ce pas cher téléphone à bientôt
pour une prochaine édition
une petit écho de la forêt il adorera
s'ennuie vous ne connaissez pas ils
adorent enchère téléphone au la grande
isadora de l'opéra mais elle a été très
chaud
[Musique]
you into oui et moi vous mangez zadora
belle seuil nma mesplet vouloir jouer à
l' ou perché 1 à 4 coins conway où le
poids parce que je m'ennuie il est de
race en mieux et on faisait part à toute
la forêt simone oui c'est bonne nuit qui
mouilleront quasi farce
pourtant on est bien ici il connut
autant avis élégante à tunis
on ne viendrait plus passer ses
week-ends non j'y vis tu veux mon cul ah
ben voilà on y est
ben aoun commission
je vais tout aussi étonnée jpy louis se
creuser la tête pour trouver une idée et
todd dans ce livre mais on va la faire
jouer au web et au rugby un sondage
aider ça serait étonnant que nos b et c
est ce qu un seul attaquant faisons lui
faire de la broderie ou gay tricot
museau dort on se dit bon du ni droite
et tosca à la demande des conseils à
mademoiselle de la cigogne vous n'auriez
pas une idée étonnante
non je regrette pourtant vous êtes
intelligente c'est vrai vous avez aussi
de l'imagination
saurez vous connaissez beaucoup de
choses
c'est vrai et vous ne pouvez pas étonné
isadora nous c'est étonnant oui et non
je m'étonne moi-même même boris se
creuser la cervelle
il crut avoir trouvé
voici ville rose est bien loin et cette
fois ils adorent oui oui oui être toi ou
être très belle je le sais moi vous
aimez moi vos lois du pouzin bon tonneau
vous et tout nu oui si vous étonnez vous
restez avec nous s'il ne paie pas
d'épouser police à noël vous parle non
lieu parce que tu m'a étonné fou de joie
est fier de son astuce boris couru
annoncé la bonne nouvelle à tout le
monde moi être étonné d'être étonnant
vous nourrissez temps ça m'étonnerait
mois avoir décidé chez isadora habitudes
en forêt pour toujours et vous trouvez
cela étonnant oui et qu'il a été solide
et à long terme a tout simplement
demandé au mariage et à la voix si être
lettonie y voient mazel il vous a jamais
dit mané en mariage hu a eu jamais
pourquoi on ne voit pas ou alors à
longmont cherbourg il se ne suis pas si
redoutable huawei plutôt petit médias
allons allons petit boris je ne suis pas
si impressionnante
en fait moi jamais avoir passé jamais
jamais si cet automne ont décidé boscher
téléphone nous avons des aux étonnants
me binet oui c'est étonnant
un bientôt pour une prochaine édition
étonnante du petit écho de la fourrure
voyons voyons rayant quelles sont les
surprises que nous réserve notre journal
au haut et coûter cher téléphone
isadora a eu une bonne initiative
culture troublant dans ce cas moi je les
paie pas lesté inactive cultive des
légumes
je vais me couper les quelque chose
d'original tu ne trouveras jamais ma
poule me connais pas aussi il c'est
ainsi qu'ils s'adoraient mois suivant va
très bien avec des plumes violettes et
vertes
vous gardez l'esprit des filles je me
trouve très bien comme je suis mal il me
faut des clients vous ouvrez un commerce
une salon des mois foule
on aura tout vu et isadora continue à
chercher une clientèle pour son futur
salon de coiffure je veux pas te défrise
able to say sur lie avec des boucles pas
question comme tu as toi max eelv et
éteindre les plans blancs et les femmes
un corbeau vélo ça ne s'est jamais vous
ai jamais décidément avec vous on est
passionné avant qu'ils se retirent
isadora couru toute la forêt mais
personne ne voulait croire à l'utilité
de son salon de coiffure ainsi bolus
yatabaré bien prisé comme moutons luma
j'aime autant et moi pas vouloir manger
moi alors il ya menace hammon salon de
coiffure rue big mac avait ce faire
comme moi mieux kim possible il faut que
c'est magique qui me coupe qu'ils y
voient du momment de beaucoup au parquet
quand il était cantatrice j'ai voyagé
beaucoup y aller quand les bestioles
c'était un bon ça alors toi faire venir
tout le monde attend maison et aussi
tous qu'ils adorent 1 se précipita chez
les frères k stores ça c'est une bonne
idée mais c'est pas il n'y a que toi
pour avoir des idées pareilles mais
c'est pas alors vous allez vite vous met
au travail mais fort des tables des
chaises on bat les etats unis lavabo et
two way to c est tout non il est pas
tout il faillait vous facilite hier
des mains pour une idée c'est une bonne
idée les sites et maryse à doha à une
bonne ici native on dit initiative whi
autrement dit elle a eu une bonne idée
et il a eu beau et des ah oui la lune
bon luciani filles et enfin je veux dire
qu'elle a une bonne idée ou et figure
toi zip
dès qu'il a pris l'initiative qui avait
hissé d'eurasie parti comme une flèche
chez mademoiselle de la cigogne aux
croyances et l'avarice yat-il et nous il
était rudement souhaite en tout cas je
n'irai jamais pourquoi maison enfin mon
pauvre aussi pu vous me voyez entrer
dans un bistrot visez pas avis transmis
trois bistrots ans je n'ai pas à besson
c'est un endroit où pour nourrir tous
bombardé ans durant a fait des jeux
d'eau 40 ondars abricots j'ai horreur du
kabuki des abricots à ivan aura
mademoiselle volaris ghosn pense à corps
et vous avez eu pour une fois une bonne
initiative que matthias belmon pourront
jamais aller dans votre barre pâquis une
demoiselle de mon rang ne se rend pas
dans un bar disons alors un café il ne
s'agit pas de café non plein maison
enfin c'est un endroit il a bien non oui
si c'est là où le club au club
bref un club dont ces conditions si
c'est un club un club a plus de classe
eh bien c'est dit j'irai dans notre club
mais oui cette chaire isadora a eu une
excellente initiative de créer un club
dans notre forêt cela manquait n'est ce
pas cher téléphone un club à bientôt
pour une prochaine édition du petit et
coûts de l'offre et voyons rien coeur
raconte notre journal aujourd'hui oraux
aux tiens tiens tiens
boris le loup a du vague à l'âme
pourquoi ce brave boris y at il du vague
à l'âme
ouais très triste et de piquer cigogne
est répartie ou à me sentir seul
lourdement seul à avoir peur pour toi
pas comprendre l'animal mais barré c'est
un animal c'est un accordée aux cours
d'eau mais vous est un instrument de
musique
écoute moi pouvoir faire musique aussi
avec cordoba vert et boris à la
charmille notre charmante de scop pas
wacogne lui si tu appelles musique sont
abominables je suis plus tortueux où le
temps ait tenu du sien être musicien
c'est un métier est un métier ça
s'apprend puisque personne aimée
m'amuser moi aller très loin en faire
comme très bien hybris tous tristes
s'éloigna mieux que sa période mais
comme moi prendre à prod
marys ouah je connais la musique comme
toi prendre le j'étais en vacances avec
des rossignols et ils m'ont donné des
cours pas connaître aux unions mais tu
me connais moi
alors voici ce que je te propose et on
ne revit plus boris pendant des jours et
des jours si bien qu ça devient qui est
un mets moi at-il d'emploi allait nous
tablions passé où la vie des réserves
dans les petites icônes et la forêt et
tu n'as pas on de rire pendant que nous
faisons tout le du mauvais sont pas
venus pour lui il était si mignon avec
son accordéon
il ne serait pas si mal que ça après
tout est le nuit tout triste tombe à mai
sur les douze coups de minuit
au ls et luzy ravissante
à
je te bats
retirez de l'accordéon
boris était trop fins de retour au
boulot ou hébert cordero maintenant
avoir appris à l'école c'est bon signe
au nom des rickshaws boris paix des
braves judiciaire
tout fier est tout heureux boris donne
un concert à nos amis tous réunis
[Musique]
curling
on dit que la musique adoucit les moeurs
c'est vrai mais il faut savoir en jouer
et pour savoir en jouer il faut
apprendre comme l'a fait boris n'est ce
pas cher telle est fan à bientôt pour
une prochaine édition du petit écho de
la forêt voyons voyons
est ce que notre journal est au courant
mais oui mais oui sur téléphones écoutés
aujourd'hui inauguration du club mais y
met un club doit avoir nous alors l'abbé
collationne vous plaît oui beaucoup
le jus de carotte me plairont
complaisent les faire astaro bien
travaillé huawei
il tombe pile de jus de carotte
je sens que je suis toute rose je devrai
compter ses graines de tournesol al
sentex sera encore un petit jus de
carotte céleri séduit pas raisonnable
hisse à doha ce n'est pas tous les jours
que y inaugure mon club
est-ce que mazel de la cigogne va venir
à l'inauguration n'a elle a mal à la
tête
elle va quand même elle est trop
curieuse je ne crois pas comment te
paraît un jeu de karaté dont bhl parler
d'elle le temps passait et mademoiselle
de la cigogne n'arrivait toujours pas et
pas chez thomas
ici c'est une grande dame si le belge
andy des sapeurs
moi je savais qu'elle ne viendrait pas
et peut encore venir
les hippies là comme l'éclair 10
secondes plus tard à zéro la sig en bref
- vale dans la cigogne pia tulle pour
faire des travaux à temps au club on ne
le dirais pourquoi personne n'est venu
me supplier devenus les mais vous savez
pourquoi parce qu'on va oublier mais non
madame avait relaxé donne maintenant je
suis venu s'y mêlent tout le monde a
fait que vous allez arriver la dernière
courbe à fond pour est une grande dame
et je suis la dernière est vrai et
demande pour que vous alors qu'il peut
faire mon entrée et à certains aulas
vous êtes et c'est ainsi que
mademoiselle de la cigogne fit une
entrée remarquée dans le nouveau club à
a pas autant mademoiselle que notre club
mais non mais non c'est aussi naturel on
vinyl com
oui je suis navré je suis la dernière
oui félicitations les frères k stores
c'est une réussite r si c'est la vérité
oh mercy mercy fille du lait vauban
demoiselle cigognes nous avoir besoin
des veaux de quoi s'agit-il
et bien on voulait retrouver non à notre
club
quelle bonne idée et que diriez vous de
le club de la cigogne les attaquez vous
dans mon club c'est vrai alors pourquoi
pas le club d'isadora il n'y a pas qui
mois dans notre équipe c'est vrai alors
je ne vois pas et les mois vie trouver
le pia pia club
plusieurs clubs ouais vide et pour le
pire période zep au village club
pis la fiesta comme ça
isadora grâce attaquant là
ce très bel endroit du sud
non plus
c'est vrai c'est vrai on va bien
s'amuser
princesse devient club on sera plus
jamais ça beaver
[Applaudissements]
c'est normal mais ne peut pas lui
réussir un tour de main il paraît que
c'est chouette
à bientôt faire téléphone pour une
prochaine édition du petit écho de la
forêt
voyons voyons voyons quelles sont les
dernières nouvelles au tiens tiens tiens
mademoiselle de la cigogne est parti en
voyage vieux et bien omar sy caritas caf
je suis je suis essoufflée et pourquoi
parce que j'ai couru comme une folle
pourquoi sais tu ce que j'apprends et
après vous allez tu à augmenter lé parti
quitte à l'étude mademoiselle de la
seaco le fromage la tome du bec
merci max casse pattes il mademoiselle
de la cigogne est parti décidément la
nouvelle faisait de l'effet à tout le
monde cependant obtient bien club
bah ouais tel parti au maroc dainville
là non elle a dû aller voir sa famille
en alsace et rogressé à noël wilzig on
pense que l on les paie non pelées billy
elle est comme ça elle se sent si deux
personnes
le grog à l'hôtel ou son portable ou par
là aussi du départ de mademoiselle de la
cigogne chez les frères k stores ça va
nous reposer un peu car à un peu
fatigante
en plus elle est d'un third on croirait
qu'à kehl au monde
en votant qu'elle paraît mémo pire club
on allonger la liste des défauts de
cette pauvre cigognes je me contiens
commune petit bain quand les rêves
gourmande et revues email et entend
lutter à la libération des défauts de
mademoiselle de la cigogne coûte-t-il
mais aussi chez les frères castor est
jalouse et vex
je vais vous dis une bonne chose il a
très bien fait partir les jours
passèrent et mademoiselle de la cigogne
ne revenait pas un poulet quand même
donné des ses nouvelles cet ol l ça va
sans dire où elle va et elle nous laisse
dans l'inquiétude mais qui es tu devenu
le ton change a très vite parmi nos amis
de la forêt avait pour les fermes et
maisons mademoiselle c ghosn lourdement
russe
et s'il lui était arrivé un accident
corso je ne sais pas pendant son voyage
elle s'est peut-être cassé une aile où
bat il faut nous avouer une chose cette
modique sigle commence à nous moquer et
peu à peu on commence à évoquer les
beaux souvenirs
j'aimais bien la voir le matin qu'elle
faisait son jogging
elle avait beaucoup d'élégance il faut
dire qu'elle sait c'est à dire et puis
elle a beaucoup d'aces paraît
et puis lève les roses et puis à la
banque plus un land beaucoup service un
peu tout le monde et elle râle pour la
forme parce qu'elle est timide et alka
sa timidité sceau des grands airs mais
les adore alors moi je vais vous dire un
sans elle notre forêt n'est plus la même
comme si comme personnalité eh bien ça a
piqué les pactes et je me sens tout
triste je n'ai plus qu un bon ménage
je ne travaille plus man en plus moi
plus jouer encore deux ans
et bien moi je sais un lecteur je ne
mangerai plus de l'étude tant que
mademoiselle de la cigogne ne sera pas
revenu
foire mais oui cher téléphone on dit que
les absents ont toujours tort vous voyez
bien qu'il n'en est rien en tout cas à
bientôt pour une nouvelle édition du
petit écho de la forêt ployon vos yeux
brillants quelles sont les nouvelles
aujourd'hui certes et les fans ou
mademoiselle de la cigogne envoie un
message est spécial on n'arrête pas le
progrès c'est la compagnie mais qui êtes
vous
je me présente je m'appelle pipeau pour
vous c'est un pigeon infirmatif je suis
un pigeon mais un pigeon faux et je
lance alors vous voyagez beaucoup
affirmatif j'ai fait le tour du monde
plusieurs fois plénière fouet fouette
pipeau comme vous voyez j'arrive tout
droit de venise des revenus locatifs
j'étais famille là bas et vous êtes
velits dvlish phonogrammes des visites
négatif
je suis en mission un spécial en dix
spéciales c'est du pareil au même
donc je suis venu en mission est spécial
vous êtes un espion négatif
j'ai un message à m omondi piaf le club
vous la connaissez celle où alors tuer
le messager spéciale tandis qu'une carte
postale venant de venise venise à avoir
beaucoup plus jour ma famille et c'est
pas de montrer votre famille que vous
êtes venu de gatumba petit d'homme c'est
une touriste qui m'a demandé de vous la
portez et auris affirmatif
vous savez une grande chose un grand
chose note sur pattes au dessus avec un
long bec et lombez et qu'il fait tout
plein de manières mademoiselle ainsi
qu'un tout juste augus et qu'est ce
qu'elle dure sur le coeur vous avez
qu'un mur
philippe est pas fière de mes lunettes
moi aussi moi n'essaient autrement dit
les membres de pia pia club ne savez pas
lire mais ne voulait pas l'avouer à pipo
le pigeon tué plongée ou savais pas
mais si vous n'avez pas vos lunettes moi
avait-il alors si vous savez lui rue on
dit viser c'est du pareil au même
l'urée mon pote et baisse est due aux
cartes postales rocher vient de
mademoiselle droite qu'elle nous dit nul
vu ce qu'elles écrivent alors on dirait
des patrons de cigognes
alors il va mieux je vais bien et je
vois bien à bientôt seuil est signée la
cie mission accomplie nous amis ne
voulant pas être en reste voulu aux
copies pour le pigeon ramène un message
pour mademoiselle de la cigogne
il faut une carte postale y en a trop
peu tard à faire une photo vous tirer le
portrait atout c'est sa foi une carte
postale tout le monde europlace
la photo prise par pipo le pigeon fut
très réussie mais il y avait encore un
problème alors qu'est ce qu'on lui dit
il faut quelque chose de gentil de
personnes effectuent oui oui avec toi et
surtout original elle y trouver voilà ce
qu'on va l'être
nous allons bientôt signer nous avons su
la compagnie faux partait déjà furent
battus nous pas manger petits morceaux
avec nous négatifs jeux consoles
correspond à bientôt deux furent battus
d'un rien et ce brave pipeau le pigeon
parti à tire d'aile
ils veulent et si vite que chaque poste
ils voulaient battre un record du monde
c'est parti
bientôt pour une prochaine édition une
petite et coude le ferai voyons voyons
quelles sont les nouvelles d'aujourd'hui
auront voilà qui est inquiétant pipo le
pigeon est honni provost pipeau il ne
bouge plus
pippo est très moche mal on y respire l
art hilda tu rigoles dormions tous le
poteau que vous faites mais qui pond
nous sommes inquiets pour toi toi et les
couchers depuis deux jours et tous dans
tous les temps s'il n'y pas normal
bonjour votre bio je récupère bien et
les berckois deux bords du nom tipi pour
je t'apporte du fortifiant au regarde de
la liturgie jeux prévus au cordeau murs
à lui la coupe du canapé pas les laisser
comme ça wade c'est ce qui lui vaut un
quad au docteur mais nous n'en
connaissons et mais moi j'en vois déjà
et je vais le chercher en egypte d'état
là il revint deux heures plus tôt heures
un couple nu brillamment l'enbrel entre
la vm docteur est pas au crac il dit il
oui le malin de feghouli vos docteur kay
a du mal à digérer
et moi j'ai des crampes quand je cours
trop vite mois à voile parfois mal au
dos et moi j'étais vertige et titi titi
tout le monde on l'y attend
je voyais fait venir pour élèves et puis
pan le peso au lit lui aussi mes
docteurs
il y est déjà donc il est malade s'est
également dit prêt à voir si tout
l'monde suivi le célèbre docteur
hippocrate au chevet de ce pauvre petit
bout
soit pas moi je vais très bien merci
je vous cause de moi gilles ans que
ressentez vous mais répondez moi vous
m'avez d'une meute de barry 11 ans que
oui
l'ancien rugbyman au moins nous avait en
moi sinon ils se baladent étant malade
très malade il a eu chaud
les plus tristes n'est pas très près par
un donc ce malade souffre de fatigue
générale mieux vaut une erreur donc il
lui faut du repos encore lui reprend
toujours du rebond
le beau ça il faut le faire manger
manger
[Musique]
le docteur hippocrate se retira et le
traitement qu'il avait ordonné commence
à moyeu bioforum du tour de la question
il faut obéir au docteur rester au nid
du coup rien pour tout un peuple de la
cigogne est peu attendre fait deux mois
qu'ils aient fait des allers-retours pc
ce qui t'a fatigués rabouillé anata
purée et hu à la télé je veux qu un tout
la dr a dit qu'il fallait effet mazet
encore manger de temps normal et le lot
2 me typo ne se sentait pas très bien
le docteur hippocrate furent appelés à
son chevet
i
ce malade étant mal à l'aise commence à
savoir qu est ce qu une digestion donc
lui faut de la tête encore de la diète
tourner la diète 2,6 des mots ce docteur
hippocrate ne sait pas ce qu'il veut
comme tous les médecins n'est ce pas
cher téléphone
à bientôt pour une nouvelle édition du
petit écho de la forêt autour
voici une nouvelle qui aura nouvelle les
nouvelles écoutes et sur téléphone deux
oiseaux célèbre entrepris le tour du
monde
et oui les oiseaux vivent tout aussi
avec leur taux est à toi et moi le tour
du monde
adèle de la cigogne répit pour le peso à
la tb et violé le petit écho de la forêt
à part des le nouvel avait bien vite
fait le tour de notre forêt ça fait
combien de kilomètres le tour du monde
le tour du monde fait plus de 40000 km
toi tout ce qu on voit plus comme on le
sait alors nous ne pas être tout le
monde ou pia pia club
ou comment est aussi le tour du monde de
nos deux amis ils vont traverser les
eaux ses amis les maires les cinq
continents l'europe l'afrique l'amérique
l'asie et un level games et adolescents
le boulot à l'orgue
c'est visible l'océanie et j'allais le
dire ils vont voyager on pack bourg un
bateau à voile
comme tous les avions en avion
impossible mais vise à combler monti zip
tube likabet les pipots son guide
oiseaux et a alors ils n'ont pas besoin
d'avions pour voler le lendemain matin
boris fut réveillé en sursaut bon
tout y est dit là qui sait être c'est
moi il s'adonna mais qu'est ce qui est
arrivé à vous faites vos valises nous
battons vous partie neuza l'ont fait
tous les deux le tour du monde comme
tout le monde moi est lui même très bien
alors il jouera toi conte et tosca pour
que vous preniez votre élan mètres pour
coiffer nous a volés mais moi pas
pouvoir voler commence à moi pas voir l
moi être loupé à oiseaux c'est que vous
êtes comme très lien moi j'ai une idée
qu'elle est dû si vous appreniez avoli
mois à voir ici et avec pipo mois est
retombée c'est qu'il est maladroit et si
les frères k stores tu mettais des aides
du avoir essayé non moi et tu tombes ou
moi j'ai une idée
david oui et s'ils adorent à transporter
boris sur son dock répondu il n'en est
pas question
vous êtes très contrariante laquelle
fait le tour du monde à pied pour les
méthodes de l'istv ou est très maladroit
alors moi l'idée laquelle j'étais un
avion il n'est pas de crest yonne
vous êtes traité tout le soir venu
isadora et boris se retrouvèrent au
clair de lune
qu'elle est belle soirée quel beau pays
pour gagner parce que vous vouliez
mobilisés à faire le toit du monde et
connaissent épine ici chers derrière
tout de même à plein de la volée chéri
zadra elle passe son temps à se
contredire ne lui en voudront pas trop
elle est si frappante à bien tous chers
téléphone pour une nouvelle édition du
petit écho de la forêt voyons voyons les
petites annonces au but
elles sont vraiment petit en pâture
voilà qui est intéressant cher téléphone
ouverture d'un cours de chant à court de
championne katia très intéressant pardon
très intéressant vous vous être fait mal
mais il ya mashov la voie à l bouillir
et vous brûlez les trains puissent
assister aux cours de chaud et c'est
ainsi que tout le petit monde de la
forêt se réunit pour assister aux cours
de shows donnés par isa dort un ancien
choix en tueuse de l'opéra il me
présenter ma première élève le jeune
boris baurès si l'ess n'a la classe où
tu sais tu es bien bonus
tout comme instagram moi pas osé
doremi ses dauphins mois avoir oublié
l'autre sous la tente et je vous en face
ils allaient tous en choeur oui fera la
[Musique]
savoir ma leçon 4 do ré mi fa sol la si
moi plus avoir le dessus au chapitre de
la gamme des mois par des chiens pour
monter au suivant la fin du cours
isadora avait donné des devoirs à chacun
de ses élèves
je réserve nos six iep écoute d'eau à
aimer ça sol la si do wah est très mal
eux jamais savoir gamme
c'est pourtant facile écoute dans comme
domino comme et domino à marennes chance
et qu'on mer et des choses me comme midi
mepha comme et moustapha sall
so i le lendemain au cours de chant de
mademoiselle isadora de l'opéra donc on
met domino récupérer des chaussées mais
comme me dit pas comme moustapha sol
comme tournesol la commettra lala qui
commet lucie dos comme et dodo et
bourhis 10 sur 10 mars marie eba tenait
tous en choeur comédons suis comme vichy
la commettra yaya sonko métaux des fonds
propres roe benmostefa by kobe midi grec
rohmer et des sauces et autres baies
domino
où j'ai l'impression que notre boris sur
un très grand acteur d'opéra
n'est ce pas chercher les fans à bientôt
pour une nouvelle édition du petit écho
de la forêt me fagot